So the answer is a bigger sample. If we chose this one also, and let's say these
two, so we double our sample size. Then you see we have this small value 32%.
And that's going to drag down the sample statistic X bar, the average. So, this
will be closer to the population average mu. And of course, ideally, we'd want
the entire population, but often times that's really hard to do, because the
population might be so big. That's when we need a sample. But a bigger sample
will better approximate the population parameter. Another example where samples
can be misleading is predicting the outcome of the presidential election. For
this last Presidential election with President Obama versus Mitt Romney, a lot
of polls were given out which each came up with its own result. Some of them
predicted that Romney was going to win, which as we know didn't happen. While
each sample may not perfectly predict population parameters. The sample
statistic can give us an interval in which the population parameter lies, as
long as the sample is random and as unbiased as possible. We'll go more into
depth about samples later.